how many do you need oh hi everybody we
are here with one of my very favorite
people in the video games industry
Shigeru Miyamoto the director of
Nintendo's game development group and
the creator of Donkey Kong and super
mario brothers and legend of zelda and a
fine human being all around and actually
we're here talking about some of the new
games that Nintendo has announced
including wii music so why don't you
tell us about wii music please well i
personally play musical instruments and
the thing about musical instruments is
that they're difficult to learn and so
even for me looking at professional
musicians i am often feeling very
envious of them at how well they're able
to play and so for a long time I've been
thinking that if there was a way to take
advantage of a hardware system to help
the user play musical instruments and
feel like they're playing them well then
that would be an experience that would
be very fun for people and so then I
started to think about what is fun about
playing an instrument and really
identified two things one of them is
that it's fun to move your body to
actually whether it's plucking the
strings or or making the notes on
whatever instrument you may be playing
it's the action of moving to create that
music and then the second thing that's
fun about playing an instrument is being
able to produce the notes themselves
that combine into a song but the
challenge is that people who aren't very
good at playing instruments or don't
know how to play instruments at all even
if they are able to do the motions they
need to do to make music oftentimes
they're worried about producing the
wrong note or simply aren't able to
produce notes that sound good together
and so with wii music what we wanted to
do was to be able to let people do the
motion of creating
music and then on the software side
helped them create the notes that they
need it and so unlike other music games
it's not a challenge based it's not like
rock band or guitar hero it's very much
about simply performing and having fun
with no rules sold a snit on all you
know that you've got dough well I think
in the the music games or rhythm games
that we've seen up until now the
objective has always been to see how
precisely you can replicate the song in
the way that they want you to replicate
it and with wii music our goal is to
rather than having people try to
precisely replicate a specific song to
give them the freedom to play that song
however they want so that even if two
people are performing the same song they
could end up performing it in entirely
different ways that both sound very very
good and so with wii music what we've
decided to do is for each song if people
want to there's six parts to each song
and if they want to they can play each
each part in a way that that accurately
replicates the way that the song was
composed and that can be one objective
for people is to just to perform the way
to solve as intended the other thing
that you can do is with each of those
six parts you can choose whichever
instrument you want to perform those
particular parts and by doing that it
gives you the freedom to then rearrange
the song you also have the freedom to
improvise away from the rhythm and the
notes as the song was originally
composed and perform your own unique
version of that song and then beyond
that you would also have the ability to
change up the tempo and do your own rent
your own arrangements of a song so for
example for one song you would have the
freedom to do a reggae arrangement and
the jazz arrangement and any other type
of musical arrangement by combining
different combinations of instruments
and adjusting the tempo however you like
I'd really like to I'd like to also ask
about the wii motionplus controller that
was just announced this this seems to
have been something that game developers
were really asking for this ability you
know do you know the wider range of
motion for the controller is that why it
was developed so listen all week yes
when we first released Wii and Wii
Remote obviously one of our
directives was to bring the ability to
use your your body to control games to
use motion control to his broad an
audience as possible and we needed to do
that at a price point than was
acceptable and so taking that into
account the technology in the Wii Remote
we thought was very strong for allowing
people to do very broad motions to
control games and so we were very happy
with what the original Wii Remote was
capable of doing but on the flip side as
both internal and external developers
began looking at motion control and ways
that they could implement that in games
you know both myself personally and
other developers came up with ideas for
which they needed more detailed control
the ability to more minutely track
individual motions and things like that
and so as we started to realize that
there were other ideas out there and now
that that motion control itself has
become so firmly established we felt
that now is a great time to to continue
to work on the technology and release
wii motionplus to allow some of those
ideas to come to fruition it because I
have many other directors who sit within
150 feet of my desk directors who in the
past have worked on games like like
Pikmin and other franchises and so I'm
they're all very close to me and they're
all working very hard well please please
continue to work hard for all of us it
was very nice talking to you again you
thank
you